no no no no non lo faremo fare loro pare
non fare non fare quartiere dai funghi
ha pensato saltasse in aria di brooklyn
una volta non fatto il sottofinale te lo
giuro ragazzi eletti ragazzi e benvenuto
questo video sono pari dei pedaggi siano
tra di sud e curling che sarebbe il
gioco tipo hunger games sono qua con i
pvv orti che sarà interrogato esatto che
sarebbe il ragazzo di cui parla sono
così ci sono ci dica qualcosa di
intrattenute vole divertente
intelligente in questo momento apparato
riproduttivo maschile perfetto volevo
spiegarvi ragazzi che negli scorsi vi
l'avete visto la scritta ipv6 gis che
sarebbe i piselli volanti sigis sono il
mio secondo non bisogna dire il crudismo
e l'ho già detto io l'avevo detto in un
altro video sarà anche mia nonna che
siamo i servi di roma e lui fa parte del
clan de i piselli volanti si chiama
cortese e l'hai detto tu a tua mamma che
fai parte dei piselli volano signor dice
dice che è molto fiera da ciò che è
felice di avere un figlio come me papà
l'altro giorno si è messa a piangere
mio figlio finalmente entrato a far
parte del ghiaccio siamo ecco a 323
metri di pura gioia da fare allora intra
altro anno entro ai ragazzi non sono
pace che hanno introdotto delle cose
tipo benessere col coltello è la roccia
vuoi fare
la città non si sa con che tipo che tu
strofinando due sassi esce fuori in
accetta non si sa comunque fisica però
questa qua fa male l'importante quel
punto ci stanno spiando con le
videocamere fire games fighissimo siamo
contro scalari j che sarebbe la prima
versione sclerata come se non lo fossi
abbastanza ragazzi qua è tutto aperto il
che non è il massimo della vita perché
sento dire di qualcuno che apre le cose
migliori fu inclini qua è così veloce
che c'è qualcuno che sentono rumori di
armadietti arrivare i variegati ti viene
incontro arrivo lo prendo la dietro ma
già oggi a questa ondata punk
[Musica]
oddio mar cercato non vedo cazzo
lasciando andare andare contro no no no
allora sono in due sono i due amiche mi
chiede una pietra
ma perché su aiuto si prende la
accettati in bocca e non si fa niente
giusto ma quanto facciamo pagare al suo
gioco dai sono 26 di vita [ __ ] di
morire come sarà la volta accordi sono
morto sono morto da ne sono accorto
morti sono morto core via viceconte
linate visto perdente simbolizzato io
corro via intanto 7 di vita però non
vincerò mai davvero ancora qui bello e
stati va fatto un lancio di mastai a
mezz'aria la roccia bellissima ragazzi
arrivano in due voglio attuare il mio
piano incredibile malvagio che è quello
di suicidarmi ma mentre mi suicido
attivo il biohazard forse proprio un
terrorismo
no figlio di una cagna in calore del
canile di di sua madre ancora un secondo
e sarebbero stati tutti in aria sarebbe
stato fighissimo di harvard in commenti
a freddo su questa partita bellissima
persa contro morgan freeman con la
sigaretta
abbiamo giocato bene ma la squadra non
aveva inter
i passaggi non andavano gameplay sai
abbiamo perso i passaggi cresce il gioco
disco al proprio cross la prossima volta
grazie mille vedete io lab 80 65 è più
facile trovare l'acqua nel gioco che
senti che bello so se te io perché devi
vivere due davano possa fare a prendere
dell'acqua no perché sono muoio fanta
niente ragazzi non si beve mentre che ho
trovato il telefono possono bloccare su
facebook fermi quello che qua sotto
6 potevi drogato vai eccolo
ma ecco perché se lo sapeva anche lui al
maine tracker mi ha sparato come uscito
madonna che potevi faccia amica questi
sanno giocare perché non siamo non
sappiamo giocare solo noia scappa che
l'utente la pubblicità scappare e
scappando vai
e vabbè mi spara pure impossibile la
fiera il martello dall'onta mia ragazzi
ci sono io
questa è la mentre share ve lo regalo
riguardi che andata senza motivo a caso
è stato uno è morto rigori è tanto
quello di prima aveva attaccato al muro
ha visto nella partita dai va bene
facciamo un'altra maliki la prossima è
quella giusta te la senti cucine di
fatica muthana [ __ ] di unicredit a
di meraviglia denunciato perché io
quando vado in giro devo trovare sempre
gente dai muori niente sono molto parca
traiana né possibile c'è una testa di un
uomo morto
cosa in trovando negli armadietti di
utile minchia la testa di un uomo morto
o hai vinto la partita l'ha rimpiazzata
pubblico si trova alle lettere io quando
ho iniziato a vivere da solo a casa mia
sono introna di quelli di amazon che ti
consegnano le cose ci nutriamo ande e
trovarti schiaccianoci non ce l'ha certo
se non ho mai un gara i corni prendi la
faccia feroce e spara in bocca ai
un'arma devi vincere to1 verso sono con
un drone in testa mai che ci puoi fare
mai che ci pare pare che tutto verde lui
tutto tutto cazzuto c'è un ananas in
testa vince una nassa io dice vabbè ma
che spiega vai vai spaccargli la faccia
a yara sono in due una volta al tipo
niente niente come niente vi sparato in
faccia a un impossibile
eccomi eccomi sono carico per questa
partita che andremo a perdere al vedere
dire raggrupparci subito io prenderei
subito diventi ogni volta ci mettiamo
sei anni m i vantaggi non è comporlo
sono le cose che curano giusto
non lo sa fare non fare loro fare non sa
fare non fare più dai funghi
pensiamo a salvarsi in aria di brutto in
una volta hanno fatto è saltato in aria
te lo giuro di quella tra naja bastarda
toccando niente avessi blood e varie
sono stronzo capace la porta qui
entriamo mantenuto il conte ma come ma
non entrava dentro è bossi che entra
entrate entrato sono morto dai ma porca
[ __ ] refah entra nell'edificio
beh che esce non è tanto non sono
riuscite ad uscire dall'edificio giusto
cinismo è certo ma vedrà il lato
positivo guardalo entro oggi si è
riuscito a uccidere una persona come lui
a milano cristo come lo recupera esagero
no no no
[Musica]
2 deficienti se contro uno
oddio è spento tutto però adesso si crea
esattamente così perché se il tecnico
mancato di televisori vai vai vai estate
di vincere vincere vincere per i piselli
volanti die die stadt e alla stessa vita
stata la stessa imparati anche un po
nikon d200 l'altro quello è proprio
barca merda sì sì bravissimo
vabbè dai bravo bravo bravo ma io ci
sono ben due persone in questa partita
attenzione perché dobbiamo suonare che
siamo sempre a sei chilometri e mezzo
l'uno all'altro non sono mai sono
sposato che avrebbe il casinò di rubin
thorne e ho trovato del sagace la testa
di un tizio trovato anch'io da vuoi
aprendo per noi condividiamo l'occasione
regali di matrimonio o c'è una c'è uno
show lanciavano gemona c'è una dove c'è
un tizio che lì dentro e io gli faccio
deve fare il culo da ma proviamoci
antologici scopo
io l'ho visto l'ultima io mi paro tuo
piccolo backstage
ma qualche cazzo di milo di merda gioco
non è morto ma devi ucciderlo mica come
l'ho preso che violenza regano come l'ho
presa seriamente questo sport madonna
che azione che azione cazzo così i copri
culo mentre mi curo ei 6 stormo lo senti
anche tu che stia decollando un lama
riley drop arrivo arrivo lo abbiamo
fatto troppa gente che non mi ha visto
come sono fatta non vedermi in mezzo
all'acqua tipo comunque unione tanto in
mezzo c'è una casa la vedesi calcio è
però aspettare che proveniente vado no
no no no sono in due o si passò così
pazzo perché già il compagno dai gente
ed io sono qua davanti sono brutti pure
non so per sono visti per forza doveva
meno che non son orbi e vistoso testa ma
[ __ ] vabbè dai combattiamo madonna
che ha fatto esplodere quel collo un
chip e lucidissimo nomi e cognomi curò
mi comunicò rincorro perfetto dove
l'altro dove l'altro c'è come hai fatto
ucciderlo
non lo so io gli ho fatto un casino di
dannoso come bravissimo mica ti adoro
fatti demon aree dove sei quanti qua o
no e 26
non lo so ma mi stanno sparando da un
tetto che ti raggiungo sono rimasti noi
2 contro loro due
dai che ce la giochiamo bene vinciamo
tutte le prime ha preso straw ioni di
merda capisco riparato dietro un albero
in tempi simo proprio su queste cose non
si mettono bene per quali altri di
attività dietro idee
l'hull sono drogato
una dai [ __ ] dove sono vedo niente
sono cieco piero [ __ ] chi cazzo
maucci chi è questo cos'è chuck norris
da eravamo arrivati alla fine però
eccedente rispetto le partite normali è
già qualcosa ma ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio è stato è stato bello se non
nel senso ci hanno fatto il culetto però
nel dubbio abbiamo ucciso una persona e
la testa siamo migliorati
io ho ucciso un tizio e lui ha ucciso
morti e ucciso me però è solo un inizio
niente inizio per giocare un imminente
ragazzi quindi servito perché sono la
seduta sopra momento è un mi piace è
capace di facebook come diviso tra te e
me lo script non so se il city siete lì
ci pigliano così via